[Applause]
[Music]
there are a thousand ways to overthrow a
dictator from violent revolutions do
peaceful transitions but Venezuela is
trying something rather unique its
parliament has just named an alternative
president to Nicolas Maduro his name is
Juan Guido and he's the man who will
lead the country into democracy if he
can actually pull it off
[Music]
and let's be clear here Venezuela is now
under a dictatorship Nicolas Maduro is
dictatorship and I know you are you
thinking right now you might be thinking
well Simon how can it be a dictatorship
they totally have elections in Venezuela
and yes they do but people could also
vote in Bangladesh Egypt and Azerbaijan
even in North Korea they have
legislative elections every five years
and people could even choose among
different political parties I'm not
being sarcastic you can definitely
google that if you don't believe me but
look if you want to have democracy
elections they must be free and fair and
of course you need freedom of speech and
freedom of speech in Venezuela is as
scarce as toilet
[Music]
basically all the websites that a
critical of the government abandoned
that includes those using a link
shortener like bitly most of TV is
nationalized or owned by friends of the
governments and opposition newspapers
they can't be printed because the paper
industry is a monopoly that's held by
the government now yes you might still
say you know but dear he's very popular
among the people isn't he hasn't that
right well I mean of course he is in
fact every dictator in history was
beloved by his people you see one of the
first lessons in the dictators handbook
is never stop spending on propaganda and
another lesson is of course send all
your enemies to prison once you have the
courts in your pocket it's easy to
accuse anybody of any kind of crime in
Arabic dictatorships they usually claim
their opponents terrorists in medoras
Venezuela they just label them as
conspirators
and now you might be thinking well
shorts I mean we get it Madeira is a
dictator but proclaiming yourself as the
legitimate president without winning an
election isn't that kind of a coup and
this is what people kind of a saying
nowadays but the fact is the opposite is
kind of true a coup d'etat is defined as
the taking of a government through the
use of force by a group that has some
kind of power inside of the system
usually the military but Ron Guido is
using an article in the Venezuelan
Constitution instead article 233 allows
the president of the National Assembly
that is one widel to temporarily occupy
the presidency of the Republic in the
case of an absence of power since Maduro
got to power by violating the
constitution there is no president now
from a legal point of view so now the
new Venezuelan executive has 30 days to
call for elections so yes m'dear is
opposition is overthrowing a dictator by
following the constitution to the latter
and this is why so many governments
including Trump's America introduced
Canada have recognized mr. Guido as the
legitimate president of Venezuela but
there is still a big question that we
have to ask here is this good or bad
news for Venezuela is it that easy to
just end the dictatorship can you just
go claim the presidency and then wait
for America to recognize you and that's
it
[Music]
well to viewers you might expect of
course the answer is no if there's a
lesson we can learn from history on this
subject it's that even countries with
the worst dictatorships can get even
worse just look at Saddam Hussein's Iraq
or Gaddafi's Libya
so is Venezuela heading towards this
same fate or are the reasons to be more
optimistic about Venezuela's situation
well today we're actually not going to
answer these questions because it's
pretty impossible to do so but we are
going to give you the keys to
understanding them but before we do as
we always do let's take a look back at
the history
end of democracy remember this date may
the 1st 2017
in this moment Venezuela's Parliament
was mostly made up of members of
murderers opposition party of course
we're all just talking about a party
that opposed Maduro in fact there are
many of those and they range from
left-wing to right-wing but nobody
really cares about them since 2016 its
parliament has been declared
disrespectful this means they no longer
have any legal power why not well
because according to the government
there were three MPs that won an
election in an unfair manner
and big surprise here three MPs was the
exact number that they needed to avoid a
2/3 majority in Congress with the
two-thirds majority the executive power
would be in dire straits and this is why
nicolas maduro finally acted to [ __ ]
the opposition do you know I'm summoning
the constituent power to achieve the
peace this republic needs we need to
destroy this fascist coup d'etat we need
the people with their sovereignty this
was the exact moment where Maduro
declared the parliaments illegal the
only opposition he still has was
politically killed and one of the next
well basically Maduro made a brand new
parliament the so called constituency
assembly this was a parliament with 500
of 40 MPs Webb surprise-surprise 503
were members of the government's party
strange as this sounds the movement
could still be considered legal
according to Venezuela's Constitution
Article 348 says that the president can
create a council to make a brand new
constitution the problem those MPs from
the same political party were making all
kinds of laws including tax laws it was
in fact just two parallel Parliament's
in the meantime the old Parliament's
with the different political parties
kept holding sessions that it didn't
really have any power the army and the
police they were on Medeiros side this
was when Venezuela went from kind of
being just this sketchy democracy closer
to financial collapse to a classic
dictatorship but hold on a minute
because there's another important part
here this fake Parliament called for
elections and as you can imagine with
nearly all of the members belonging to
the president's political party those
elections were as predictable as the
ending of The Passion of the Christ yes
you guessed it
Maduro he won by a landslide but of
course no serious country recognized the
results of these elections already in
2018 Mike Pence the American vice
president said this about Maduro
[Music]
United States has called this election
what it really was a sham Maduro must
hold free and fair elections release all
political prisoners immediately and
unconditionally Mike Pence
vice-president of the USA
the same happens in most South American
and European countries nobody recognized
the results of this election the problem
was they that there was no alternative
to maderos rule and this is how we got
to January of 2019 when Madeira took
office of course he didn't do it before
the National Assembly because he don't
like those guys instead he took office
in front of the Supreme Court of Justice
according to the Constitution this means
that he made his oath illegally and
therefore he is an illegal president
having no legitimate presidents the
president of the National Assembly Juan
Cueto made another oath and this is when
all of those countries who didn't
recognize the outcome of the elections
started recognizing grideau as the
legitimate president of Venezuela all
rights in any way you think he was it it
was just five minutes after grideau
became president the Trump basically
recognized him as the leader of
Venezuela he's is that just pure chance
or maybe there was a plan in place
already well let's take a look at that
here's about Venezuela if you've been
following visual politic for a while you
read you know the Venezuela is the
country with the biggest oil reserves on
the planet even bigger than Saudi
Arabia's Russia's or Americas the
problem though is that they can hardly
make a profit on them
you see it's one thing to have lots of
dinosaur juice and it's entirely another
to make money off that juice just have a
look at this very chart here you can see
the production cost of a barrel of oil
by country Saudi Arabia has the cheapest
per barrel production cost this is why
even at low market prices they always
make a profit on a per barrel basis
nonetheless Venezuela's on the other
side they have one of the most expensive
oils to produce and if that's not enough
pdvsa venezuelan state oil company is in
chaos
total production of oil in Venezuela has
dropped precipitously from 2.7 million
barrels per day to 1 million barrels per
day this is why despite being the
country with the biggest oil reserves on
the planet
Venezuela produces less oil than Angola
or Nigeria in fact they represent just
seven percent of the oil imports in
America this means their weight in the
International economy is pretty small
this is especially true at a time when
America is surpassing Saudi Arabia in
all production yep
America no longer that crazy about oil
on the other hand you've also got Trump
restricting investments in Venezuela
this means thanks aren't really exposed
to anything that happens in Venezuela so
you really don't care
and then of course the White House still
doesn't like Madero that's why they've
named Elliott Abrams as the special
envoy to Venezuela Abrams by the way was
one of the people behind the iran-contra
scandal as well as Venezuela's coup
against shadows in 2002 but let's be
honest
Trump has many things to think about
besides Venezuela in Spain and generally
the spanish-speaking world Venezuela is
on the front page of all the newspapers
everyone talks about it in the bars and
cafes of Madrid there is a debate going
on by those who support Madero and those
who don't but if you're in America you
might know that something has happened
in Venezuela that you're probably aren't
too passionate about it nonetheless
guess which country has a rather large
stake in Venezuela and I'm probably
gonna give it away when I say that it
begins with AC it's not Colombia
[Music]
China now taking 28% of Venezuela's oil
production to repay them as we said in
previous videos China needs natural
resources so they made big loans to
Venezuela so far Caracas owes Beijing
more than 50 billion dollars that's the
cost of three Olympic Games but since
Venezuela no longer has the money to pay
their debts they have to pay China with
oil and if you still wondering why China
still supports Madero well he's the only
one who can guarantee the oil shipments
add to this drug trafficking according
to several DEA reports between 15 and 20
percent of the cocaine trade goes
through Venezuelan soil important
figures such as Diosdado Cabello would
be directly involved in narco activities
Venezuela is a sort of narco state in
the sense that it's a place where
traffickers can establish their
logistics hubs with the help of
government officials all right so all of
this is fine but the big question is can
there really be a peaceful democratic
transition in Venezuela well let's
explore that
what can be done about this as we said
before Venezuelan opposition is
completely fragmented they have lots of
political parties conservatives liberals
socialists but unlike other countries
like Poland or the Czech Republic where
they had strong leaders that opposed the
dictators there is no clear opposition
to Maduro
but well now things have changed with
international support one Guido can
really galvanize the Democratic
opposition of course he's just the
interim president and this means that in
30 days you will have to call for
elections but this is kind of where the
good news actually ends
[Music]
you see laws they're just empty words if
there's nobody to enforce them this is
why the military and the police are so
important here in other words Guerra
might have all the legitimacy he ever
good ones but how can he call for
elections if the army doesn't want this
to happen
this explains why both Grider and Maduro
have been trying to seduce the army
[Music]
Nicolas Maduro demanded loyalty to the
army
we must enforce the power of the
Venezuelan nation with the military so
far the Army is on the dura side at
least at the time we're recording this
video just the quick parentheses here at
the moment we are editing this video
this is February the second general of
the Venezuelan army has just bloated a
youtube video claiming that he supports
one way though and he rejects the
authority of Nicolas Maduro the name of
this army official is Francisco Steven
genius Rodriguez and you can find the
link to his video on the description
below most high ranking officials are
completely loyal to his rule and in the
past few years Caracas has been raising
the salaries of the soldiers today the
average Venezuelan soldier can make more
money than a surgeon but still it's not
that much money in fact we're talking
about the equivalent of about $80 a
month in other words soldiers are still
poor just like the rest of the country
so is this enough to make the army a
rise up against Maduro well we don't
know but it is something to take into
account and what about all of those
high-ranking officials well that's a
whole other story
in fact they live really a lot better
don't believe me well let's take a trip
through the Salamanca Quarter
Salamanca is the Spanish Manhattan it's
a luxury neighborhood in the center of
Madrid
everybody here is well-off and as a
sidenote they vote conservative in 2010
only some Venezuelan officials live tip
some of them even made investments but
in recent years more and more Madeira
officials have been arriving in fact
some people are starting to call the
area little Venezuela many times I'm in
a restaurant here in Madrid and next to
me there are people I would be scared to
see in Caracas said Leopoldo Lopez he'll
father of Leopoldo Lopez a Venezuelan
political prisoner for example the
personal nurse of Hugo Chavez brought
property for 1.8 million euros here in
2015 of course she did it in cash and
just like her other people have come
with briefcases full of money ready to
buy luxury properties even the daughter
of the Minister of Defence lives in
Madrid in other words murderers
officials are sending money to Venezuela
in order to prepare for potential exile
some go to Madrid of this go to Miami
few good Bogota and here's a good way to
put some pressure on the army economic
sanctions on government officials would
restrict them from making these kinds of
investments this is nothing new though
in fact this is the same policy the
international community has with North
Korea these kind of measures they put a
lot of pressure on the military so that
they'll start thinking about turning to
the democratic side but all right what
if the army still is supporting the
dictatorship I mean what would happens
then can a dictatorship survive even if
America doesn't recognize it and the
answer is yeah
for example Mao Zedong's China was not
recognized by Washington for years the
White House considered Taiwan's
government to be the legitimate
government of China and something
similar could indeed happen in Venezuela
another possibility is an open civil war
the army could fight grideau who would
ask for international help in fact there
are rumors that America might be sending
some troops to Colombia or so we've
found news that claims that some
mercenaries have been crossing the
border from Brazil fake news or not we
can't be sure but it would kind of make
sense
[Music]
nonetheless and this is just our opinion
but it's hard to believe that America or
Europe would risk so much for Venezuela
and Maduro himself he doesn't want to
war civil wars can have unintended
consequences for dictators especially
when they want to leave their
presidential palace overnight and a
group of opposes captures up with them
weak just look what happened with
Mussolini or Ceausescu or Gaddafi but
this is like I say it's just our opinion
and now it's your turn
what do you think will happen in
Venezuela is it time for this country to
recover its democracy or will Maduro
remain in power for many years to come
well please leave your answer in the
comments section below also don't forget
to visit reconsider media the podcasts
that provided the vocals in this episode
that were not mine and as always
remember that we publish brand new
videos every week so subscribe to visual
politic and hit that Bell button so you
don't miss out on any posts if you like
this video give it a thumbs up and as
always I'll see you next time and if you
want to learn more about politics and
hear more of my lovely voice don't
forget to check out the reconsidered
podcast at reconsider media.com we
consider as a podcast that challenges
you to reconsider your views by
providing context but we don't do the
thinking
[Music]